Which is the hardest word to translate in this sentence?
"Know" is easy to translate.
"Pep rally" doesn't have a direct analog in a lot of languages and cultures,...
...but can be approximated.
But the hardest word there is actually one of the smallest: "you."
As simple as it seems, it's often impossible to accurately translate "you"...
...without knowing a lot more about the situation where it's being said.
To start with, how familiar are you with the person you're talking to?
Many cultures have different levels of formality.
A close friend, someone much older or much younger, a stranger, a boss:...
...these all may be slightly different yous.
In many languages, the pronoun reflects these differences...
...through what's known as the "TV distinction."
In French for example, you would say "tu" when talking to your friend at school,...
...but "vous" when addressing your teacher.
Even English once had something similar.
Remember the old-timey "thou?"
Ironically, it was actually the informal pronoun for people you're close with...
...while "you" was the formal and polite version.
That distinction was lost when the English decided to just be polite all the time.